there is nothing more important to the
story of armor core 6 than Coral the red
substance shows up everywhere from The
Game's title to the motivations of every
character to each of the game's endings
it's not just an energy source it's a
data conduit we learn that it is even a
living growing organism understanding
Coral is essential to understanding ac6
especially since air are partnering
crime throughout the game is literal
Coral in this video I want to explain
what Coral is and how it works so well
as the anchor to fromsoft's Mecca story
I will bring up spoilers so don't watch
if you want to avoid that and I hope you
enjoy
the influence of coral is everywhere in
the game the fires of Ibis have
basically set the game World up and they
were a burning of coral when it began to
grow too fast Handler Walter wants to
burn the coral again since it has begun
growing once more his whole life is
dedicated towards coral and his goal of
Burning It All Away obviously the
corporations are also on Rubicon for the
promise of coral they want to use it as
an energy source and for augmentation of
their pilots the rubiconians themselves
also direct their lives around coral
using it to raise mealworms for food
even our own existence as pilot 621 is
dependent on Coral we are a fourth
generation Coral augmented pilot because
of this Coral connection we can make
contact with air one of the main
characters of the game and a literal
Coral wave mutation this connection is
Central to the game's final main player
all mind who seeks to bring about coral
release in its ending so we have all
these tendrils of coral throughout the
game but what is it well if we look at
Professor mcgai's second log we can see
he calls Coral sheer potential
ratatosker has a great video touching on
this Coral represents potential both
literally in game as in energy source
which lets humans do new things and also
metaphorically as it represents the
concept of potential in the story every
character and action everything all
turns on quarrel when one has coral one
has the potential to do nearly anything
and we see that in the final ending but
first let's talk more about the literal
side we hear that Coral is a society
changing energy source and data conduit
and we learn that it's also some kind of
organic hive mind that can
self-propagate it was something poised
to improve Human Society through or
exploitation of it but then it started
growing too fast The Institute got
worried about this growth and its
possible mutations what they could mean
for Humanity so Ibis was deployed and
Rubicon burned unlike nagai we get to
see what happens if we don't burn a
coral growth in the Alia Yak the s
ending we see the results of the coral
growing so much and getting so dense
that it spawns a black hole with the
help of us in air some of the only coral
and non-coral beings to be in contact as
I said in my ending video we don't have
a clear picture of what happens here but
we also don't need to fully know the
ending's meaning that the dye is cast is
something we move forward with nagai and
Walter and thumb Dom Del Mayan even all
feared this unknown because they were
not sure what it would bring they
couldn't allow themselves to let it
happen the guy and Walter sought to burn
the coral
sought to prevent the rubiconians from
going down the path of contact and
casting the die
but interestingly it seems this growth
was caused by humans obviously Rubicon
has existed as a planet for a long time
but we only hear of the coral growing
and needing to be burned after humans
began to exploit it after it was used as
an energy source to make Ibis and to
create augmented humans we opened
Pandora's Box and Walter makes sure we
realize once something's alive it
doesn't die easy
Walter thinks the solution is that you
just have to be really thorough about
killing it I.E glass the whole star
system twice but I don't think this does
the job I don't think we can go back the
die of coral has already been cast and
we need to deal with it I think the
similarities between Ibis and the fires
of Raven are meant to show that this
Burning doesn't do the job Coral doesn't
die that easily once some new potential
is found how can you go back to the time
when it didn't exist you can't close
Pandora's Box after everything's Escape
you can't just ignore new potential I
don't think we can kill the coral I
don't think we have the ability to in
game if the fires of Raven ending just
repeats the mistake of Ibis and if the
Liberator of Rubicon ending just pushes
the need to deal with the issue down the
line and we are only left with Aaliyah
yakta s following all mine's plan at
least until the final fight
air has a key piece of dialogue about
all mine's motivations she says
Humanity assumed its current form to
fight itself
to choose from infinite selections
that is the essence of the human race
and the key to biological evolution
Perhaps it is also a clued to what
online's true goal is
the idea here is that what is core to
humanity is the choosing amongst
infinite selections infinite potential
we grew and evolved to be the unique
species and people we are by fighting
ourselves and choosing for ourselves
amongst infinite selections we are
beings who bring new possibilities into
existence to choose from them to better
ourselves Coral is a compliment to this
it brings opportunities to fruition
Coral release is the greatest example of
this it happened when all of rubicon's
coral grouped up together from nagai's
first log we know growth happens quicker
with density the massive Coral group
experienced a positive feedback loop of
growing getting denser and growing more
and at the Apex of this we in air is the
one point of contact release the trigger
the coral collapses into a black hole
and somehow disseminates Among the Stars
a gravitational collapse happens but we
don't know if it's also a collapse for
humankind like nagai beard the coral is
everywhere and we are unsure of what
that means the ending is ambiguous all
we know is there is no going back and
that the potential of coral has been
injected across space
whereas the fires likely fail in their
goal to burn all the coral and Liberator
just pushes release down the line This
ending goes through with the inevitable
step of evolution it passes the point of
Choral inflection humanity and her core
identity of choosing selections has been
given the perfect substance to go
forward in that tribe with the Coral in
some great contact with Humanity we now
have the greater potential to seize
those infinite choices to have our
humanness Amplified to an unknown degree
the die has been cast and now we must
decide if we lament Humanity's change as
a collapse or if we move forward in this
new world
despite being everywhere Coral is
ambiguous this lets it work as a
fantastic storytelling device for rumsok
it is given some properties to set the
stage and motivate characters being an
energy source and kind of organic it
also has metaphorical meaning but it
doesn't get caught up in the weeds of
lots of technical details more is left
up to the player's imagination and this
lets the player fill in their own blanks
and get more invested this is a common
method in storytelling that allows the
audience to engage with the story on
more personal terms and get more into it
Coral being a stand-in for a broad
concept like potential makes it fit to
be described with minimal details Coral
lets the world move and not worrying as
much about every aspect of its workings
helps to limit players getting caught up
on technicalities and small details that
don't matter as much
all these features of the coral help it
to tell the story of Rubicon 3 and offer
us all these Sublime moments that we get
with the game's characters it lets us
experience them and they're desperately
real human drives
in doing the research for this video I
Really fell in love with coral as part
of the story of Rubicon and as a unique
aspect of the final ending I hope you
enjoyed this look at the red substance
and let me know if you want to see more
armored poor thanks to my patrons for
your support and thank you for watching
see you in the next video
peace